Hi ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's wieder etwas aus Kiki's Backschule!
Wir machen heute einen Schokoladenbiskuit Boden.
Und ihr wisst ja mein Biskuit Boden ist echt so das Nonplusultra unter den Rezepten
weil's einfach immer gelingsicher ist!
Ich bekomme so viele Fotos von euch zugeschickt!
Und heute gibt's eben die Schokovariante.
Hier hab ich die Zutaten. Nix exklusives, alles ganz normale Zutaten, die ihr alle da haben müsstet.
Und zwar Eier, die hab ich hier getrennt, die sollten sauber getrennt sein.
Dann hab ich hier die trockenen Zutaten: Mehl, Back-Kakao - nicht den Trink-Kakao, das ist wichtig -
Speisestärke und natürlich Backpulver. Hier hab ich Zucker und optional könnt ihr gerne noch etwas
Vanilleextrakt dazunehmen.
Wir machen jetzt zuallererst eine Baisermasse. Wenn man die nämlich später schön unterhebt,
dann wird der Teig besonders fluffig.
Und ich geb jetzt dafür das sauber getrennte Eiweiß in die Rührschüssel meiner Küchenmaschine.
Ihr könntet auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden, aber dann braucht ihr ein bisschen länger.
Wichtig ist wie gesagt: es muss sauber getrennt sein.
Ist da auch nur ein bisschen Eigelb drin, dann schlägt sich das einfach nicht mehr auf
und dann müsstet ihr wieder von vorne anfangen.
Ihr könnt auch alternativ gerne die Eier immer wieder mal schlagen, in einer separaten Schüssel
und dann erst in die große Schüssel geben, dann habt ihr keine Verschwendung.
So und jetzt schlag ich das so ungefähr 45 Sekunden oder 1 Minute, geb dann die Hälfte des Zuckers dazu
und dann weitere 2min auf höchster Stufe steif schlagen.
Und die Baisermasse ist schön standfest!
Ich hab da jetzt gerade noch eine Prise Salz reingegeben weil erstens hilft Salz, dass die
Eiweißstruktur ein bisschen schneller "zerstört" wird und andererseits wisst ihr ja:
bei süßen Sachen immer eine Prise Salz und bei herzhaften Sachen immer eine Prise Zucker,
dann rundet das auch zusätzlich nochmal den Geschmack ab.
Und die Hälfte des Zuckers hat eben bewirkt, dass es so schön standfest wird wie jetzt.
Ansonsten, wenn ihr keinen Zucker dazugebt - falls ihr euch das fragt -
dann wird das eher so schaumig-fest, aber nicht so.
Also das ist ja schon wirklich sehr standfest.
Ich hol mir jetzt eben mal ne neue Schüssel und dann schlag ich Eigelb
zusammen mit Vanilleextrakt - wie gesagt das ist optional - und Zucker ebenfalls richtig schön schaumig.
Nach 4min auf höchster Stufe sieht unsere Eigelbmasse jetzt so aus, also sie ist richtig schön hell geworden,
schön cremig, ein bisschen dicker geworden.
Und da heben wir jetzt die Baisermasse unter.
Da nehmt ihr euch jetzt einen Teigschaber, ganz ganz wichtig: keinen Schneebesen mehr verwenden!
Denn wir wollen ja die Luft, dass die enthalten bleibt und eben nicht entweicht.
Und daher jetzt in 3-4 Schritten schön mit ganz viel Liebe unterheben!
So, die Masse ist jetzt schon ziemlich fluffig!
Und da geben wir jetzt noch die trockenen Zutaten hinein.
Die müsst ihr vorher unbedingt sieben!
Ich nehm mir einfach mein Handsieb und ich mache das immer so: Ich geb nicht das alles komplett direkt rein
sondern ich sieb immer ein bisschen, dann hebe ich unter, dann siebe ich nochmal...
Weil so könnt ihr auch sicherstellen, dass die Masse von dem Gewicht nicht erdrückt wird
und nicht zu trocken wird.
So, der Teig ist jetzt fertig und jetzt müsst ihr euch nur noch entscheiden,
in welcher Backform ihr backen möchtet.
Da könnt ihr verschiedene Formen nehmen: eckig, rund, eine Herzform, eine Blumenform...
Und dann gibt's ja Springformen, die benutze ich auch sehr, sehr gerne.
Oder Tortenringe. Heute nehm ich mal einen Tortenring und schlag den jetzt zusätzlich nochmal in Backpapier ein,
das zeig euch jetzt auch mal ganz kurz.
Jetzt den Tortenring einfach aufs Backblech geben.
Und ich erinner mich grad zurück, wir hatten ja ein Café damals.
Also wir haben es ja vor 5 Jahren geschlossen.
Meine Mutter hat im Keller immer Torten gebacken und die Arme, die hatte dann nie einen Tortenring.
Irgendwie gab's den früher nicht, zumindest nicht bei uns.
Und dann hat sie immer hier einfach nur die Form genommen, hatte keinen Springform Boden mehr
und hat den dann in Backpapier eingeschlagen
(H: *lacht*)
Da musste ich jetzt grad irgendwie dran denken.
Naja, auf jeden Fall gebt ihr jetzt den Teig hier rein, könnt den jetzt noch an der Oberfläche
so ein bisschen glattstreichen und es ist auch immer hilfreich, wenn ihr euren Backofen vorheizt.
Jetzt wird der Teig gebacken bei 180 Grad Ober- und Unterhitze wie gesagt im vorgeheizten Backofen
ca 25min, macht aber auf jeden Fall die Stäbchenprobe. Bis gleich!
Nach dem Backen ganz einfach zugedeckt auskühlen lassen, dann kann die Oberfläche
jetzt auch nicht austrocknen.
Und danach könnt ihr's durchschneiden.
2 Mal, 3 Mal, ganz wie ihr möchtet.
Ich werd euch in die Videobeschreibung die ganz genauen Mengenangaben aufschreiben,
nochmal ganz, ganz wichtige Tipps, die ich da unten dann auch nochmal hervorheben möchte,
damit ihr das auch nochmal lesen könnt.
Und was enorm wichtig ist, wenn ihr jetzt eine andere Größe haben möchtet, eine andere Höhe,
dann schaut euch gerne auf meiner Webseite die Umrechnungstabelle an.
Da könnt ihr dann einfach schauen: "Welche Größe möchte ich?"
und dann habt ihr da die Umrechnungsformel.
Mega, mega praktisch!
Jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken,
ich hoffe ihr hattet Spaß hier bei Kikis Backschule!
Und dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten Video.
Und schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare welches Basic Rezept nicht fehlen darf,
welches ich gerne noch für euch abfilmen soll.
Und natürlich würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr dem Video ein Däumchen nach oben da lasst,
Und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Video! Tschüss!